you got a chance to also
together with other engineers and with
Elon sort of look brainstorm when you
step into a code base it's been around
for a long time you know there's other
social networks you know Facebook this
is old code basis and you step in and
see okay
how do we make with a fresh mind uh
progress on this code base like what
what did you learn about software
engineering about programming from just
experiencing that so my technical
recommendation to Elon and I said this
on the Twitter spaces afterward I said
this many times during my brief
internship
um
was that you need refactors before
features
um this code base was and look I've
worked at Google I've worked at Facebook
uh Facebook has the best code uh then
Google then Twitter
um and you know what you can know this
because look at the machine learning
Frameworks right Facebook released
pytorch Google released tensorflow and
Twitter released
okay so you know it's a proxy but yeah
they're the the Google Club is quite
interesting there's a lot of really good
software Engineers there but the code
base is very large the code base was
good in 20 and 2005. right it looks like
2005. there's so many products so many
teams right it's very difficult to
um I feel like Twitter does less like
obviously much less than Google
in terms of like the set of features
right
so like it's I can imagine the number of
software Engineers that could recreate
Twitter is much smaller than to recreate
Google yeah I still believe in the
amount of hate I got for saying this
that 50 people could build and maintain
Twitter uh pretty what's the nature of
the hate comfortably
that you don't know what you're talking
about you know what it is and it's the
same this is my summary of like the hate
I get on Hacker News it's like
when I say I'm going to do something
they
have to believe that it's impossible
yeah because if doing things was
possible they'd have to do some soul
searching and ask the question why
didn't they do anything so when you say
hey and I do say that's where the hate
comes when you say well there's a core
truth to that yeah so when you say I'm
going to solve self-driving
people go like what are your credentials
what the hell are you talking about what
is this is extremely difficult problem
of course you're a noob that doesn't
understand the problem deeply
uh I mean that that was the same nature
of hate that probably Elon got when you
first talked about it Tom was driving
uh but you know there's pros and cons to
that because like you know there is
experts in this world
no but the mockers aren't experts the
market the the people who are mocking
are not experts with carefully reasoned
arguments about why you need 8 000
people to run a bird app there but the
people are gonna lose their jobs well
that but also there's the software
Engineers that probably could have says
no it's a lot more complicated than you
realize but maybe it doesn't need to be
so complicated you know some people in
the world like to create complexity some
people in the world Thrive under
complexity like lawyers right lawyers
want the world to be more complex
because you need more lawyers you need
more legal hours right
um I think that's another if there's two
great evils in the world it's
centralization and complexity yeah and
uh the the one of the sort of hidden
uh side effects of software engineering
is
uh like finding pleasure and complexity
I mean I don't remember just taking all
the software engineering courses and
just doing programming and this is
coming up in this uh
uh object-oriented programming kind of
idea you don't like not often do people
tell you like do the simplest possible
thing like like a professor a teacher is
not going to get in front like this is
the simplest way to do it they'll say
like this is direct there's the right
way and the right way at least for a
long time you know especially I came up
with like Java right like is is there's
so much boilerplate so much like
so many classes so many like designs and
architectures and so on like planning
for features far into the future and
planning poorly and all this kind of
stuff and then there's this like code
base that follows you along and puts
pressure on you and nobody knows what
like Parts different parts do which
slows everything down is the kind of
bureaucracy that's instilled in the code
as a result of that but then you feel
like oh well I follow good software
engineering practices it's an
interesting trade-off because then you
look at like the ghetto-ness of like
Pearl and the old like how quickly you
could just write a couple lines and just
get stuff done that trade-off is
interesting or bash or whatever these
kind of ghetto things you can do in
Linux one of my favorite things to look
at today is how much do you trust your
tests right we've put a ton of effort in
comma and I put a ton of effort in tiny
grad into making sure if you change the
code and the tests pass that you didn't
break the code yeah now this obviously
is not always true
but the closer that is to true the more
you trust your tests the more you're
like oh I got a pull request and the
tests pass I feel okay to merge that the
faster you can make progress CEO is
programming with tests of mine
developing tests yeah with that in mind
that if it passes it should be good and
Twitter not that
so it was impossible to make progress in
the code base